bentornati oggi video etico va da creare
il floris live view è figo al mondo la
pizza gigantesche dovuto fare in questa
super piscine dalla fede alla sua e
trasparente 4 che possiamo anche vedere
attraverso per un velo di vedere come
sia balla di utilizzare tutti
ingredienti non tossici quindi tutte
sostanze non pericolose vi posso vedere
quello che ha prodotti lizzare 30,53
ciascuno 40 sono in altra da un litro
poi voglio abusare la schiuma da barba
stazione per leggi per attivarlo
bicarbonato di sodio sempre per
attivarlo lozione per il corpo
samo prenderlo bello bob lee profumato
poi glitter colorante alimentare
[Musica]
se volete vedere giganti mete nicole è
in te ho subito che iniziamo con la roma
non sarà così epico
oggi perde tantissimo però è troppo
bello ok primo strato di colla l'abbiamo
fatto ragazzi
ora passiamo al prossimo questo mega
tecnico flap islam che andiamo a creare
ed ispirato ai pattini della serie 24
settembre a trani non dei nuovi episodi
della terza stagione non vedete ministri
disney channel al meeting prendersi in
particolare lo slime è ispirato ai
colori dei fatti della stagione bresso
ammettere che la tra mille
mi sono sempre al bar e ralph fiennes
per il think sport
[Musica]
avete visto più belli e ora così fondo
contenitore di colla una cascata di
colla non so perché divertentissimo
questa feature testa col cappello e
andiamo a mettere il terzo piritore di
cosa ci si metta sta iniziando a dirsi
[Musica]
guardate 4 mio marito così tante cose
tutte una volta primo bottigliate le
cose che devo ammettere tutti gli altri
ingredienti è compatto e abbiamo la
nostra base di cola bellissimo
nella schiuma da barba nel momento di
unità
e lì
[Musica]
e non voglia di emergere tutta la mano
destra profonda dentro ma ancora no però
andiamo ora mi schiera con la prossima
da parma questa bella profonda e poi
andiamo a onorarlo curate le forme che
sarà bellissimo
ora che l'abbiamo bibbiano un po andiamo
a mettere il colorante allora aggiungo
prima lo shampoo e l'adozione così
franco rack e cremoso e il dolore di
cosplay ma mi sono ispirata ai
bellissimi colori di patti ha intimato a
usare il giallo che mettiamo il giallo
[Musica]
mi chiamo lanzone che bello effetto di
colorati fischiano tutto pochissime
corse di rosso per fare cosa ora andiamo
fischiando vediamo
e poi abbiamo petric l'inter sempre
ispirati ai colori del tricolore
bellissimo giallo arancio anche i costi
sono tutti in diretta volta abbiamo
aggiunto altri un colorante per che però
era troppo poco per questa quantità
enorme di colla e colori
[Musica]
grazie bellissimo cuore e ora una delle
mie parti preferite ora andiamo a
mettere i tantissimi fitte lorenza lei
giallo e qui vai a colori
[Musica]
ok guardate quanti bellissimi kg per non
si capisce mostri tutto in una ecco
comunque ora rischia di tutti i colori
[Musica]
cosa mettere la soluzione per letti e ce
ne vorrà bicarbonato giorno
inizio mescolare finché non inizia ad
attivarsi e abbiamo assunto la soluzione
problemi
[Musica]
ok siamo tempo per arrestarlo enorme
portata
siete pronti attenti nei suoni smr
immergere money qua dentro
se volete fare questa attività mi
raccomando fate le vostre cento e le
sostanze non sono pericolose da
maneggiare ma comunque non sono i b b
non sono inseribili mi raccomando
iniziamo subito innanzitutto guardate
quante bollicine sono formate però crea
quindi un po
com'era un po di booking no vabbè
bellissimo così grande
[Musica]
bellissimo immergere le mani col dentro
in un silenzio come spiegarlo ma è
tattico per l'am così grande a qualche
fa dei suoi fantastici ma lentissimo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e fantastico veramente sono troppo
contento di avere uno stadio che ti ci
devi sapere che come se mi è piaciuto
questo mega flop di simon gigantesco e
mi raccomando nota che devi nuovi
episodi della terza stagione di storie
di una sottile chan nell'area 24
settembre detti 35 io continuerò per
tipo colore aspetto questo perché troppo
bello e di lando mangione cosa
pensereste ciao
[Musica]